in 2008 Samsung's smartphone
manufacturing facilities were scattered
throughout mainland China just 15 years
later those factories have disappeared
and nearly all of them have relocated to
Southeast Asia it may have given Samsung
a competitive advantage to go to Vietnam
first but Apple
heels oh
giant started making similar moves to
diversify its operations here's a closer
look at how Samsung and Apple's
manufacturing moves from China are
reshaping their businesses and what the
strategies reveal about the rapidly
shifting Global Supply Chain
in 2008 Samsung set up a plant in the
baknin region of Vietnam to reduce its
dependence on China tech industry
analysts say it was a forward-thinking
move for the South Korean company they
benefit in a lot of ways they benefit
from cheaper labor in some of these
countries that they're moving to they
benefit from being insulated from some
of the geopolitical tensions that come
with operating in China and continuing
to expand in China they also benefit
from being insulated from the Kaiser
Supply Chain shocks that we saw during
the the covid lockdowns in China and the
supply chain disruptions that resulted
from that over the next decade Rising
labor and operating costs in China made
it difficult for Samsung to produce its
phones cheaply that coupled with
intensifying competition from domestic
smartphone Rivals LED Samsung's market
share in China to plummet meanwhile the
company was slowly moving its smartphone
operations out of the country since 2013
the number of Samsung employees in China
has fallen by 70 percent
Samsung still kept significant
manufacturing centers in China including
for its expansive memory chip business
Samsung semiconductor but moving its
smartphone operations meant to the
company was shielded from many of the
trump-era tariffs on chinese-made Goods
those tariffs coupled with the
geopolitical tensions developing between
the Western World and China led a lot of
companies to you know reconsider where
they're manufacturing things by 2019 it
had shut it's lost
one year later the pandemic hit
propelling tech companies like apple to
make similar moves away from China China
had a very strict coveted policy that
led to a lot of disruption for many of
these these companies and seriously
pushed them to consider manufacturing
elsewhere where that kind of disruption
would be less of a thorn in their sides
Apple's plans gained even more momentum
in late 2022 after violent protests
rocked the company's largest iPhone
manufacturing plant in jeongzhou China
demonstrations erupted when the workers
who had been under strict covet lockdown
for weeks learned bonus payments would
be delayed at the time Apple said it was
working with the facility to ensure
employee concerns were addressed
according to analysts and people in the
company's supply chain Apple no longer
feels comfortable having so much of its
business tied up in one place while
different Events first propelled Samsung
and Apple out of China their new supply
chain strategies focus on the same
places India and Vietnam these countries
some of them have offered tax breaks to
to companies to locate their
manufacturing there have been in some
cases grants and other incentives that
you know hard for these these companies
pass up Samsung pays about 10 percent
corporate income tax in Vietnam versus
China's standard 25 rate it now produces
half of its smartphones there Apple also
has operations in Vietnam the company
started producing its watches in the
country and moved some iPad
manufacturing there too
in Apple's most recent list of its top
200 suppliers 25 were in Vietnam
that's 25 percent higher than four years
ago
then there's India around 20 to 30
percent of all of Samsung's smartphones
are now manufactured there according to
Morgan Stanley and it's still expanding
in 2022 it opened the world's largest
Mobile Phone Factory near New Delhi
these moves helped the company to become
a dominant force in India's rapidly
growing smartphone market the second
largest in the World Behind China
awesome Galaxy A14 5G now at just rupees
44 per day in 2022 Samsung accounted for
around 20 of the country's total market
share while Apple held less than four
percent apple is working to change that
in a recent earnings call CEO Tim Cook
said India is an incredibly exciting
Market uh it's a major Focus for us so
this year Apple has said it plans to
manufacture a portion of its iPhone 14
models in India for the first time which
is a significant move you know the
company is essentially saying that
we want to diversify Tech analysts say
manufacturing iPhones in India and then
selling them to the surrounding
Southeast Asian market ensures a smooth
and more resilient supply chain
Apple's longer term goal is to ship 40
to 45 of iPhones from India according to
supply chain analysts in 2022 that
number was in the single digits for the
company more recently the company
started moving manufacturing even closer
to home a multi-billion dollar deal with
U.S chipmaker broadcom will allow Apple
to Source critical chip components from
manufacturing hubs around the US
but even as Apple and Samsung spend
billions to move away from China the
manufacturers may still depend on
suppliers there during the height of the
2020 covid-19 outbreak in China Samsung
found itself scrambling to secure
suddenly scarce Chinese components
there's also a political challenge
because these companies many of them
still need to manufacture in China to
some extent and they need to be delicate
about how they handle diversifying their
supply chains even though a supply chain
shift won't happen overnight Samsung and
Apple's manufacturing strategies reveal
a larger de-risking Trend that's
transforming Global markets it's kind of
like diversifying a portfolio if you
will increasingly as the US and China
that relationship becomes more
contentious in a lot of Western
companies see China as more risky and so
they're thinking about doing Less in
China they're thinking about de-risking
from the perspective of the politics of
the situation
foreign
[Music]